[Music]
how did the devastating death of a child
put bevis and butthead at the center of
a media firestorm the whole story is
almost too weird to believe bevis and
butthead do the universe premiered
exclusively on paramount plus but before
the audience even got a chance to see
the movie it was already shaping up to
be one of the best reviewed films of the
year critical response for beavis and
butthead do the universe has been nearly
universally positive however that's not
how critics have always felt about
beavus and butthead for instance when
the show premiered on mtv in 1993 the
critical response was mixed at best
despite critics often wringing their
hands over the series beavis and
butthead went on to become mtv's highest
rated program it was a massive hit among
kids and teens in 1993 and that
generation has now grown up to become
today's movie and tv reviewers while
nearly everyone can agree that beavis
and butthead is great plenty of older
fans remember how controversial the show
once was today most critics and tv
viewers understand the point to beavis
and butthead yes the characters are both
dumb as bags of rocks both of them are
obsessed with sex have juvenile senses
of humor and engage in all kinds of
destructive behavior everyone
understands that creator mike judge
doesn't endorse these shenanigans
instead the show is a satire one that
poked fun at adults perceptions of
generation xers who watched mtv however
at the time many critics completely
missed the point for just one example
the mclaughlin group spent an entire
segment bashing the show and complaining
that it represented the decline of
american television crude dumb ugly
thoughtless sexist self-destructive and
foolish the generational divide was also
a factor in 1993 a san diego union
tribune critic summed it up best by
writing i tried to like beavis and
butthead i really did in fact it
actually bothered me that i didn't like
them i always wanted to be a cool parent
i don't want to be part of another older
generation but i can't help it i really
really hate these guys strangely many of
these critics thought that mike judge
was just as dumb as the characters he
created as judge later put it viewers
really should have connected the dots
after all how could someone be capable
of producing a professional level piece
of animation and still be as dumb as
beavis and butthead appear to be still
given the overall reception plenty of
parents in 1993 thought that beavis and
butthead was too dangerous for tv
in october 1993 a five-year-old in
moraine ohio named austin messner
allegedly started a fire that resulted
in the death of his two-year-old sister
jessica his mother darcy burke then
claimed that her son had watched beavis
and butthead and that the show inspired
him to play with fire of the incident
the local fire chief harold ziegler told
the associated press the mother is
attributing the fact that he was
fascinated with fire to the beavis and
butthead segments where they are setting
things on fire when you take a child in
the formative years and you get these
cartoon characters saying it's fun to
play with fire this is going to stick in
that kid's mind and it's going to be
with him for a long time mtv didn't go
so far as to take beavis and butthead
off the air but the network did make
several adjustments in an attempt to
head off the criticism the network
decided to ban the characters from
saying the word fire removed four
episodes from the rerun schedule and
moved the show from 10 pm to 11 30 pm
hoping that only older viewers would be
watching however in a 2011 interview
with the spokesman review judge denied
that beavis and butthead had such an
influence on children saying first of
all i don't agree with any of that kind
of criticism and i don't take any
responsibility for any of it at all the
fire was obviously a very horrible sad
tragedy but it had nothing to do with
beavis and butthead years later austin
messner reportedly came forward and
clarified that he had never even seen
bevison butthead because his family
couldn't afford cable at the time the
controversy ultimately didn't stop
beavis and butthead from becoming the
cultural icon than it is today it would
go on to spawn the 1996 film beavis and
butthead do america a 2011 reboot on mtv
and the most recent feature-length
offering not bad for a show that many
initially condemned
[Music]